[Musique]
ce soir sur le divan d'henri chapier
michel lonsdale né le 24 mai 1931 à
paris d'une mère française et d'un père
anglais l'acteur le plus étrange de sa
génération n'était guère un enfant comme
les autres
fasciné par le maroc où il passe toute
son adolescence il y gagne un mystère
qu'aucun film aucune pièce et encore
moins ses toiles n'arrive à nous livrer
au départ l'extraordinaire interprète de
marguerite duras au théâtre était un
adolescent plutôt timide qui cherchait
sa vraie vocation
en 1952 sa rencontre avec tania
balachova décide de son destin après ces
trois ans de cours d'art dramatique
michel lonsdale découvre une façon de
jouer qui s'apparente à la magie orson
welles et françois truffaut le
considèrent comme le seul acteur capable
d'exprimer lire rationnelle et d'aller
plus loin que la parole baykal ans dale
quel petit garçon étiez vous à l'âge de
7 ans pourriez vous me le décrire
c'était avant tout un petit garçon
anglais british le pouvoir élever tout à
fait dans les traditions anglaises
bonhomme georgie et qui passaient du de
l'europe à l'afrique
alors là je suis devenu un peu différent
plus tard alors est ce qu'il y a une
image très forte de votre enfance que
vous n'oubliez pas
une image relié à quelque chose de
précis poursuit comme ça y'a des images
d'éblouissement oui quand nous avons
quitté la france au mois d'août 39 et
que nous sommes partis sur un immense
bateau anglais à marseille bateau qui
revenait l'australie et au tous les
employés sur le bateau était des indiens
des grands turban alors je me souviens
de l'éblouissement de cette arrivée dans
ce port de marseille le soir pour
embarquer sur cet énorme bateaux
illuminés et ensuite aller jusqu'au
maroc a été à partir de là je me suis
souvenu à peu près de tout ce que de
toute mon enfance avancer le plus confus
mais cependant vous était à paris alors
à paris vous étiez bébé pendant quelques
mois simplement avant d'aller à londres
oui jésus n'a pas rimé exporté
rapidement dans les îles britanniques
d'abord à lille de gérer pendant quatre
ans ensuite à l'ombre jusqu'à la guerre
donc élevé en milieu de fûts britannique
donc votre langue maternelle a été
l'anglais c'est la première en cause est
liée par les professeurs je parler
l'anglais jusque l'âge de 12 ans
uniquement et après j'ai commencé à
apprendre le français très difficilement
le français est ensuite devenu ma langue
principale ce qui est intéressant chez
vous c'est que dès le départ vous
parliez du maroc
or le maroc c'est votre adolescence bien
sûr c'est ça qui compte énormément
apparemment c'est un moment déterminant
le sait le choc la ligue émerveillement
sont les années de 10 ans à 20 ans à peu
près donc tout l'adolescence et de toute
la perception qui se développent et
toutes les émotions qui arrivait et la
mémoire qui garde tout ça mais vous en
avez dit un tout petit peu plus je crois
à jour que vous aviez dit que ça vous
avait surtout apporter un autre moyen de
communiquer j'aimerais bien qu'on
s'arrête un instant là dessus il y avait
l'incantation du désert des paysages du
sud
mais il ya autre chose qui correspondait
sans doute chez vous à dcl et autres
quelque chose de profond reese le mari
c'était d'avoir un pays
où l'on vive les sons sont très étonnant
les les odeurs sont étonnants tout est
très prenant comme ça a été extrêmement
fort surtout l'été et donc je garde des
souvenirs c'était pourtant la guerre la
guerre en europe pas là bas mais je
garde un souvenir de tout ce qui était
extrêmement violent au point de vue
couleurs les mérites et blanc le ciel
était bleu les oliviers et les palmiers
thé vert mais tout ça d'une force
incroyable
évidemment à ces âges là on en reçoit et
on est complètement investis de tout ce
qu'on veut voir sans la langue arabe
aussi que j'ai appris sans même m'en
rendre compte
quand je suis retourné dix ans après au
maroc je parlait l'arabe et j'avais je
me suis pas rendu compte que je l'avais
appris en tout cas si vous voulez la
façon dont on a vécu a permis une grande
liberté de de faire j'ai été très peu
contraint très peu obligé dans mon
enfance
alors ça je crois quand on pressent pas
un enfant qu'on n'oblige pas à être
intelligent ou qu'on n'oblige pas être
efficace on ne le bourg pas de notion d'
idée de choses apprises
ça laisse une place une chance au
développement si vous voulez du rêve et
de l'imaginaire et alors c'est la prova
le ainsi qu'a commencé votre envie de
peindre c'est là que vous a concerné en
plus à peindre un peu à la manière d'un
rêve éveillé en laissant l'imagination
et la main partie non oui là-bas dans
super la façon dont les gens étaient
habillés les arabes est enveloppée de
tabac enveloppé de voir l'enveloppé de
turbans faisait que si vous voulez les
les corps à la façon les costumes
étaient toujours souple et toujours
drapé et à la révision de couleur la
couleur impressionné passionné les
contrastes de quand je lis à l'heure de
bleu de blanc de verre sont tellement
violent que ça mais les chocs visuels
c'est vrai je restais complètement cube
louis à regarder un coucher de soleil
pendant des heures
quand on a eu cette adolescence et qu'on
revient à paris en quarts 9,50 je crois
d'abord c'est très gris je suppose
ce qu'on découvre et ensuite on va
s'inscrire comme vous l'avez fait cette
année à bâle acheva mais poussé par
quelle énergie ou inspiration
alors l'arrivée à paris oui c'était très
trop autres et sont très tristes était
tout noir
paris n'avait pas été nettoyés par
malraux donc difficile adaptation on
refuse pendant deux ans je trouvais ça
j'ai des trous noirs paris et j'aimais
pas du tout il a fallu vraiment que ce
en attendant les musées en apprenant à
la culture française tout doucement que
je commençais mes paris ça a été long
mais alors l'envi d'être comédien oui ça
a débuté très jeune danse et cinéma au
maroc on allé plusieurs fois par semaine
on voyait les films de trois fois et ça
a été le premier idéal de ma vie c'est à
dire de vouloir faire comme ces gens que
je voyais sur les écrans je voyais pas
de théâtre y en avait pas donc c'était
le cinéma ça prenait toute la place de
mes rêves je rêvais aux acteurs je
jouais j'inventais des jeux avec les
acteurs jeux cd je prends des petites
les petites photos dans le paquet de
chocolats
je rangeais je faisais la classe aux
acteurs en faire j'imagine toutes sortes
de choses et je me disais un jour je
voudrais être comme un pendant ses
années de paris est ce que vous avez des
coups de foudre est ce que vous êtes
senti très libre
ou est-ce que vous êtes senti un peu
brimé disons je suis sorti d'abord un
enfant sauvage arrivant dans une grande
cité est très civilisée et sachant pas
où m'adresser n'osant pas m'adresser
sachant pas où aller
les premières fois où je voulais aller
au théâtre c'était la comédie française
je suis arrivé j'ai vu des gens faire la
queue et puis lâche arrivé devant une
caisse où il y avait écrit baignoire
loges
je ne comprenais pas ce que ça voulait
dire alors ce prix balco je comprenais
pas tout ces termes
alors je suis avant tout et avancé
jusqu'à la caisse qui vont là de média
qu'est ce que vous voulez gta capable de
dicter je suis parti voyez ça va fouler
complètement est allé dans un court jose
pas trop
j'avais connais j'y d'un manège au maroc
est une ancienne vedette du muet et
j'avais même pas osé aller à son cours
il a fallu attendre à paris l'occasion
par le journal à 20 jours j'ai trouvé un
article fait une proposition publicité a
tremblé vous savoir si vous êtes
comédiens
alors à partir de là j'ai osé y aller
sinon passer des tests pendant trois
jours et puis le résultat était qu'on
m'a dit oui vous pouvez de comédien sera
très difficile mais si c'était cette
année à cheval non ça c'était un petit
peu en travers mais alors ça m'a donné
la force si vous voulez d'années à en
faire voir tenir kim a reçus à bras
ouverts je veux pas dire d'autre mot au
petit studio des champs elysées pas loin
d'ici où elle donnait son cours et là
j'ai trouvé une femme miraculeuse
accueillante généreuse qui vous dans le
regard vous transpercer l'impression que
vous voyez à travers vous et elle m'a
laissée à son cours pendant deux trois
ans presque sont payés je vais pas
beaucoup d'argent et je voulais toujours
payé puis je me dis un joueur vis dehors
mais non z en reste et restez vous
paierez plus tard et voilà donc tania
m'a accueilli à bras ouverts et mal
poussé sortie à coucher une seconde fois
c'est elle qui m'a poussé sur le plateau
de jean alesi alesi pas les images je
voulais pas je voulais refaire tracteur
mais je voulais rien faire pour le
devenir
et puis elle m'a sorti de mes groupes
comme ça elle m'a un jour demandé d'être
violon c'est dire comment violent oui
elle nous en misanthrope almadies allait
déclencher quelque chose devenait
violent
jb je sais pas je peux pas ici vous ne
devenez pas violent je ne veux plus voir
au cours
alors je suivrai faut faire quelque
chose vous voyez qu'il ya des gens qu'il
faut pousser un peu à bout comme ça
alors j'ai attrapé une chaise et je les
cas c'est bien ça ne me faudra dehors de
toute façon pas du tout elle m'a dit
bravo
c'est bien il faut il ya un moment où il
faut pour se dépasser s'oublier devenir
avoir une espèce d'éblouissement et
perdre conscience de soi dans son os à
truffaut en passant par mocky enfin vous
avez fait une gamme assez étendue de
personnages
est-ce que parfois vous en rajoutez
vous-même j'aimerais savoir ça c'est ce
qui vous arrive un peu d'aller plus loin
par votre propre volonté de tenter un
coup à la lisière oui enfin je veux le
fait car je sens un metteur en scène qui
est capable de l'accepter et qui le
demande alors avec truffaut ça a été le
premier à me dire voilà je vous demande
de faire quelque chose dans baisers
volés
je vais vous donner un texte n'allait
pas la prendre et vous allez simplement
garder le schéma et puis vous allez
improvisé là dessus je dis bien alors je
peux faire ce que je veux il m'a dit oui
je dis bon il prend des risques mais je
vais en prendre aussi alors inventé le
personnage de monsieur tabarre dans une
espèce de folie
et comme j'ai vu qu'il était très
content c'était une affaire de contacts
un rapport de création et que metteur en
scène quand metteur en scène vous pousse
à aller plus loin en vous à être vous
même à oser faire des choses que vous ne
seriez peut-être pas d'habitude par
pudeur voir timidité alors là ça devient
extraordinaire parce que quand on se
sent comme la permission si vous voulez
d'aller au delà de ce qu'on ferait
normalement
à cela on sent poindre un peu de génie
on se dit ah est quelque chose qui peut
découvrons en nous ce qu'on ne sait pas
de nous même osons être autrement et on
est plein de ressources des êtres
humains sont fabuleusement riche de
possibilités qu'ils n'emploient pas
beaucoup justement votre grotte exploit
dans ce domaine je crois
ça a été deux
de prouver en somme que les textes de
marguerite duras pouvait vraiment être
interprétée jouer entendu alors là c'est
là que vous êtes précurseur et mêmes
vous avez eu l'assentiment de magouilles
du à ce qui n'était pas imaginable tout
à fait au départ oui à bas toute la
rencontre avec marguerite s'est faite à
travers claude régy qui a été remise à
lens l1 qui j'ai beaucoup travaillé
peut-être avec lequel j'ai le plus
travaillé et claude régy metteur en
scène qui vous pousse à aller dans ce
sens de l'inconnu et dans les
possibilités à soupçonner de vous même
et marguerite étendue race étant venu
par dessus alors ça a fait boule de
neige et marguerite est quelqu'un qui
parle intelligence vous emporte aller
très loin dans vous-même et alors
l'enjeu santé un plein champ à une
pleine liberté si vous voulez c'est
inimaginable dans ça dans ma vie de
comédien il ya quatre cinq personnes que
j'ai rencontrées et qui ont été des
déclics si vous voulez que tu étais des
gens qui m'ont changé complètement
or si l'on changé devant l'impossibilité
d'aller au delà de moi-même je me suis
toujours demandé c'est un certain mort
et le travail en tant que telle n'était
pas votre toute première nécessité
intérieure en somme le travail de quoi
le travail sur toutes les formes ou
irish d'audrey de comedia le train la
radio comme au théâtre comme au cinéma
est ce que cette sorte de boulimie de
travail n'était pas simplement pour vous
le minimum dont vous ayez besoin sans
doute fait sur le v de comédien il ya
des raisons on se bat on pourrait
chercher un peu j'ai pensé souvent
pourquoi ce que j'ai tellement voulu
comédiens quoi ça correspond à ce que
c'est un besoin de cacher de fuir de pas
être moi même peut-être que le moi même
est difficile à vivre
donc s'incarnant dans toutes sortes de
choses on s'oublie on est comme
transporter ailleurs alors je sais que
j'ai une boulimie de travail oui et je
pourrais dire que je m'en lasse parce
que quand le travail est pas trop mal
fait il vous redonne des forces pour
continuer encore plus la fatigue si vous
voulez ne vient qu'à partir du moment où
on fait des choses qui sont pas bonnes
c'est la confuse on se perd mais le bon
travail et vous redonne des forces pour
continuer et c'est renouvelable à
perpétuité
on dit que vous êtes vous même capable
de faire des plats extraordinaire
non pas du tout je fais à peine cuit
vapeur act up et j'aime bien manger
temps en temps une bonne chose mais sans
ça donc je mange pas trop et d'abord je
peux pas parce que c'est pas bon pour
moi mais je suis pas gourmet du tout je
mens je entendre l'entier d'un petit son
bridge ou d'un croque monsieur ou est
bon la nourriture n'a pas d'importance
mais vous est-il arrivé de souffrir de
de la laideur dans le quotidien quelques
endroits où quelquefois vraiment j'étais
tombé dans des gourbis possible mais
enfin c'est quelqu'un qui s'adapte
énormément si vous voulez c'est une
philosophie que j'ai d'essayer de
s'adapter et des 30 jours en condition
de prendre la couleur de l'endroit où
vous êtes très britannique ça quand je
suis dans un palais je suis heureux j'en
vois les beautés quand je suis dans un
gourbi
j'essaie de me dire voilà il ya beaucoup
de gens qui vivent dans des gourbis et
donc ne pas être dépaysés il ne faut pas
un certain endroit où un certain confort
votre renom le bonheur pour moi c'est de
m'adapter aux personnes que je rencontre
et aux lieux où je suis aux situations
c'est une espèce de côté caméléon si
vous voulez qui fait que je crois que
c'est fondamental dans notre métier de
comédien de pouvoir être observateur et
repart tout parce qu'il ya à voir et à
observer ya à prendre dans tous les
endroits du monde alors dans vos
rapports avec les gens on vous dit
attentif et exigeant et tatillon je vois
les rapports de travail et peut-être
même des autres alors j'aimerais savoir
si vous pensez que les gens sont
perfectibles parce que vous avez le
souci du perfectionnisme en toute chose
mais alors peut-on changer les gens
peut-on temps ça peut peser sur leur
destin ou la vie comment et comment ah
on peut impérativement à
périlleusement a bien j'aimerais que
pièces et des rides et les rencontres
sont fait que c'est comme des atomes qui
se croisent qui se cherche je crois que
il ya des gens le terme est extrêmement
populaire et très intelligent on a des
atomes crochus avec les gens et bien
quand c'est attire mon crochet marche
c'est que ça vibre écueil est dit ce
qu'on appelle un contact un rapport à
quelqu'un
à ce moment là le monde peut changer
c'est un échange il faut donner ce qu'on
a soit de plus vrai que ça sert si
l'autre c'est pareil à son électricité
commence à naître et c'est capital de
rencontrer dans la vie des gens qui vous
électrise des gens qui vous modifie qui
vous font passer à autre chose
alors est ce que vous pensez vous que la
sexualité a autant d'importance qu'on ne
le dit aujourd'hui comme le proclame
partout
oui elle a énormément d'importance l'âme
et le corps sont absolument mêlée nous
vivons en sur deux plans à la fois
indissoluble mais qu'on ne séparons dit
le corps et l'âme et je crois pas je
crois que le corps et d'âme c'est une
seule chose donc là mais capable d'amour
le corps et qui parlent d'amour les deux
se fusionnent bon moment quand l'amour
vrai hélas entre les êtres évidemment
tout devient extraordinaire ce soit un
amour physique mon amour morale ou un
amour du coeur du moment qu'elle
générosité qui a échange réel qui est
vérité entre les aides à ce moment là
tout devient faible et j'aimerais savoir
ce que vous évoque
je prête ce dessin et les tests de
rorschach recharge comment dit-on oui
oui puisque vous le connaissez voilà je
le connais tous à mme joly papillon ça
me fait penser un papillon oui c'est
extrêmement sensible à la couleur je
regarde la matière plutôt que la forme
est enfin si vous voulez je vous dise la
forme oui c'est plutôt espèces de
papillons fleurs c'est quelque chose qui
est en métamorphose et qui tend vers la
beauté mais qui n'est pas arrivé encore
puisque nous sommes sur ce terrain je
vous ai pas demandé s'il vous arrivait
d'avoir des cauchemars des rêves
persistant alors des choses comme ça non
à pandore du fameux rêve quand tous les
comédiens c'est à dire que on vous
appelle vite pour aller sur une scène
joue un rôle dont vous savez pas un mot
et vous allez arriver en retard et vous
retrouver sur la scène et où c'est parce
que les dix qui arrive très souvent en
dehors de sable non j'ai pas de
cauchemars répétitif nom est sûrement à
un tout petit peu stupide de vous
demander ce que vous allez faire les 20
ou 30 prochaines années vous n'y avez
pas penser en ces termes
non non vous savez je suis trop
philosophique là dessus j'attends voir
j'attends de voir ce qui est selon ce
que la vie propose je fais avec et la
vie propos des meilleures choses dans ma
vie entre ses petits mans été donné
c'est parce que j'ai tellement voulu
tout d'un coup il ya des cadeaux qui
arrivent les cadeaux de la vie des
appels des moments où l'air la vie sans
vous dire maintenant il faut faire ça et
je réponds à cette demande intérieure je
voulais
[Musique]